même sous la pluie les Français ont
toujours autant d'appétit pour les
manifestations à Paris ils étaient des
dizaines de milliers à répondre à
l'appel des syndicats qui ont obtenu la
journée de mobilisation sans précédent
qu'ils espéraient il y a plus de monde
qu'on a jamais vu pour un premier maître
aujourd'hui c'est un premier mec qui est
historique c'est la première fois qu'il
y a autant de
monde pour la 13e fois en trois mois les
Français ont marché un premier mai
symbolique quelques semaines après
l'entrée en vigueur de la réforme des
retraites avec des manifestants qui
promettaient de ne pas baisser les bras
on continue la lutte elle continue
pas possible on peut pas nous fermer la
bouche comme ça on peut pas nous
empêcher d'exister dans d'autres villes
de France même mobilisation et même
revendications que ce soit à Marseille à
Toulouse ou à Rennes
[Musique]
pour nos retraites et notre ami le
bouton aussi le peuple aujourd'hui
annoncé veut être écouté entendu et il
faut pas de conscience que ça devient
difficile la vie de bénéficier voilà on
est excédé et voilà
je sais pas comment ça va se terminer
mais
j'en sais rien mais en tous les cas on
est bien barré les forces de l'ordre
aussi étaient sur le terrain 12000
policiers étaient déployés partout en
France mais la surveillance ne se
faisait pas qu'au sein des cortèges dans
les airs aussi puisque des drones ont
été utilisés pour garder les
manifestants à l'oeil
positif de sécurité qui n'a pas empêché
les débordements nuage de gaz
lacrymogènes vitr éclatées projectiles
incendie au total près de 300 personnes
ont été interpellées et une centaine de
policiers blessés dont un au cocktail
Molotov en fin de journée les
manifestations se sont dispersées avec
une question en suspens quelle sera
l'avenir de ce mouvement de contestation
le gouvernement Macron lui espère
qu’après l'orage du 1er mai viendra le
beau temps que les Français accepteront
finalement de passer à autre chose ici
Radio-Canada Paris